ich habe innerhalb von 30 tagen eine
modemarke mitgegründet eine komplette
kollektion designed und wie ich das
geschafft habe
[Musik]
das ganze hat damit angefangen dass sich
lange auf der suche nach einem neuen
wunderbar aber in meinem preissegment
nichts gefunden habe was mir vom schnitt
und vom design her gefällt reise von 100
200 oder bis zu 500 euro scheinen
mittlerweile im modebereich für boni
komplett normal zu sein das können und
wollen die meisten aber nicht ausgeben
und ich zähle mich auch dazu es muss
doch irgendwo liegen produkt geben was
bezahlbar ist und trotzdem vom schnitt
und vom design her einfach passt und
genau da will ich ansetzen module
produzieren wie es aussieht meiste
qualität hat und eben nicht 100
natürlich kaum ein anreiz auch in
gewisser weise daher dass leute in
meinem umfeld gibt die in kurzer zeit
wirklich ernstzunehmende brands
gegründet haben die absolut berechtigte
standing kaufen modemarkt haben es gibt
allerdings ein paar probleme an der
sache ich habe keine ahnung von
textilien ich habe keine ahnung von
webseiten programmierungen shopsystem
ich habe keine ahnung von versand- und
versand artikeln
ich habe keine ahnung von illustrator
was zum design der produkte benutzt wird
rundum ich weiß gar nicht wie man das
macht und ich muss aber wissen damit das
reibungslos funktionieren und damit ihr
das versteht es geht mir nicht darum das
ganze mal zu testen und irgendwie ein
bisschen auszuprobieren sondern es geht
mir darum eine ernst zu nehmende
modemarke zu gründen und das auf dem
höchsten qualitätsstandard zu machen der
überhaupt nötig ist also was mache ich
um meine probleme zu lösen natürlich
google erst mal was dabei rumkommt
spreadshirt und on demand produktionen
die wirklich überhaupt keinen sinn
machen wenn ich das auf diesem level
machen will und lieferzeiten und
qualität und schnitte kann ich dabei
komplett vergessen also was brauche ich
denn das ganze professionell zu machen
und wo fange ich überhaupt tempels also
rohlinge ein eigenes design inhalte und
models eine website und plan für druck
und produktion verpackung und versand
und das ist echt eine menge wo fangen
wir daran natürlich würde ich gerne
eigene schritte haben neben den designs
ist das eben hauptmerkmal von jeder
marke und macht das ganze konzept eben
aus wie viele andere tragen eine
klamotten eher oversize und genau nach
solchen sample sich auch deswegen habe
ich als erstes 20 verschiedene
produktionen in der türkei in portugal
überall in europa und osteuropa
angeschrieben von denen haben wir genau
fünf geantwortet und fünf davon waren
absagen
mein stückzahlen sind einfach so niedrig
dass es nicht für keine produktion
weltweit lohnen würde da irgendwelche
extra schnitte anzufertigen
genau das sind eben die probleme mit
gegen jede neue brand zu kämpfen hat
weil man hat große ideen aber es gibt
einfach keine möglichkeiten wie man das
in diesem rahmen umsetzen kann genau
deswegen habe ich mich auf die suche
nach textil großhändlern gemacht bei
denen man meist schnitte in etwas
kleinerer stückzahl bestellen kann und
trotzdem nicht auf qualität verzichten
bei so einem großhändler habe ich dann
unmengen an samples gestellt um mir
einfach ein möglichst gutes bild von
verschiedenen produkten zu machen und
dabei komplett unterschätzt was das
alleine für den kostenaufwand ist
deshalb werde ich im laufe des videos
immer wieder meine ausgaben einblenden
falls ihr also eine eigene modemarke
gründen wollte hat den guten
anhaltspunkt und wissen wo mit ihr
rechnen müssen fürs design der produkte
muss man auf industrieller zurückgreifen
mit photoshop geht das nicht weil man
vector dateien beim drucker abgeben muss
und ob unterstützt das einfach nicht
also musste ich das komplette programm
von null auf lärm photoshop und
illustrator sind zwar beide von der
lobby aber könnten unterschiedlicher
nicht sein worauf baut man meistens das
design auf natürlich auf dem namen für
kollektionen und marc das habe ich mir
auch deutlich leichter vorgestellt und
der name hat sich dreimal über den
designprozess hinweg komplett geändert
unterschätzt folgenden punkt aber mal
nicht einen guten namen zu finden ist
die eine sache dass dieser name als
domain und auf instagram aber frei ist
bis ziemlich man viel hin und her und
tagen des haupt verbrechens präsentiere
ich euch shaping the world aber warum
shaping the world' meine schaut euch um
wir haben in den letzten jahren so
geisteskrank viel auf die beine gestellt
die jugend hat ihre stimme
wiedergefunden wir gehen wieder auf die
straße setzen uns für themen die uns
wichtig sind und probieren das
politische ruder in richtung zu reißen
ist für uns alle in zukunft besser wird
und deswegen auch der produktions name
duty auf der young es ist eben unsere
pflicht die pflicht der jungen leute
unsere stimme mit einzubringen und dafür
zu sorgen dass wir langfristig was von
dieser welt haben und der marken und
kollektion name findet sich auch in
jedem ps wieder am morgen um 14 uhr
kommt ein video in dem ich die
kollektion komplett detailliert
vorstellen druck der textilien nachdem
ich die designs fertig hatte stand ich
vor dem problem einer druckerei zu ich
habe mehrere tage gesucht aber nichts
gefunden was mir wirklich 100 prozent
gepasst hat und vor allem nichts was
in der nähe war was absolut von vorteil
ist damit man die qualität und alles
überprüfen kann
deswegen habe ich ein kumpel von mir
gefragt der mehr erfahrung hat der hat
mir ein drucker empfohlen mit dem habe
ich mich verbunden gemeinsam hingesetzt
gesagt was ich machen will und wir haben
im endeffekt das projekt zusammen
realisiert ganz kurz die druck art
machten gigantischen
qualitätsunterschied ich habe mich bei
all meinen pieces für den höchsten
qualitätsanspruch entschieden und
dadurch natürlich auch am meisten
bezahlt und weiterer faktor für den
druck ist ein oder mehrfarbig kite
position des drucks und größte natürlich
fotos videos und models da bin ich in
der relativ glücklichen position weil
ich mehrere jahre hauptberuflich
fotografiert habe videos sollten auch
kein problem darstellen und models war
wahrscheinlich das größte problem an der
sache da die ganze kollektion unisex ist
brauchte ich ein männliches und ein
weibliches model im prinzip habe ich
einfach instagram durchforstet und leute
gesucht die gut aussehen aber keine
hauptberuflichen models sind damit die
keine unbezahlbaren preisvorstellungen
haben für einen tanz natürlich braucht
man für vernünftige fotos auch
vernünftiges equipment und ein
vernünftiges studio das würde eigentlich
ziemlich viel geld kosten da ich aber
natürlich mit leuten befreundet bin die
irgendwie im selben bereich arbeiten wie
ist konnte ich kostenlos das studio von
einem hobby von mir nutzen
leider hatten wir aber kein licht und
das musste ich deswegen meinem foto
verleih
sie habe die nachbearbeitung komplett
unterschätzt im endeffekt habe ich
anderthalb tage daran gearbeitet die
bilder alle gleichmäßig auf einen stand
zu bringen und die wirklich hochwertig
wirken zu lassen instagram und website
ich habe am anfang probiert meine
webseiten mit wordpress zu programmieren
habe gemerkt dass ich absolut kein
programmierer bin das nicht kann und
dass viel aufwand ist auf der anderen
seite habe ich gegoogelt und shopping
fall gefunden das ist ein fertiges shop
system funktioniert super gut es gibt
verschiedene designs und ein großteil
der website wo ihr wahrscheinlich eure
produkte bestellt sind auch einen job
gemacht dazu bietet show gefeiert
unzählige addons an die einem die arbeit
erleichtern
ich habe bei meiner website überhaupt
nicht den anspruch das rad neu zu
erfinden es geht viel mehr darum einfach
ein gut funktionierendes klinisch system
zu schaffen hier habe ich mich ja in
anderen jobs orientiert und deren
konzept einfach übernommen
die besucher sollen möglichst wenig
klicken müssen um direkt zu den
produkten zu kommen deshalb kein
schnickschnack und bis auf
produktbeschreibung keine text auf der
website verpackung und versand wieder
ein thema bei dem ich absolut keine
ahnung hatte glücklicherweise habe ich
für ziemlich schnell eingefunden was es
mir deutlich erleichtert die ganze
logistik zu managen
außerdem dhl geschäftskunden konto
eröffnet damit es zum einen günstiger
ist und ich einfach an besseren support
habe und passende kartons bei einer
firma aus der nähe von köln verpackung
ist mir aber so wichtig dass ich da noch
etwas spezielles einbauen wollte ich war
mal bei palace in new york und habe
meine klamotten in einer verchromten
tüte bekommen das ist mir so sehr im
kopf geblieben
das habe ich so sehr gefeiert dass ich
mich genau dafür entschieden haben nach
langer suche und nach langem hin und her
habe ich den produzenten in china
gefunden der mir am vier seiten
verschlossene chrome tüten produziert
die eine riskante an bedeutet ihr kriegt
meine klamotten in einer wirklich
geistes kann in verpackungen die wie
eine tüte chips auf reisen sind und wo
zur hölle bringt man circa 350 produkte
und ich habe mich dazu entschieden
meinen keller komplett leer zu wollen
ein lager regal reinzustellen und mir
quasi eine versand straße wieder
aufzubauen wir haben natürlich sachen
wie im internet anschluss ein
schreibtisch im lager regalen etiketten
drucker und noch ganz viel anderer
kleinkram der versand und vor allem der
schnelle versand sind mir extrem extrem
wichtig ich habe mehrmals schon bei
kleinen upcoming brands bestellt und
gemerkt dass das für viele das größte
problem überhaupt ist ich werde
versuchen jede bestellung an
den tag zu bearbeiten und am selben tag
rauszuschicken um genau das eben besser
zu machen weil meine kollektion aber
eben erst morgen um 18 uhr auskommen
kann ich euch noch nicht besonders viel
zum ablauf sagen und ob es gut
funktioniert hat denn das werde ich
machen
ich glaube aber das ist wirklich
unfassbar viel arbeit wird und ich bin
gespannt was es für organisatorischen
aufwand und genau das sind alle punkte
die ich durchlaufen musste um von der
idee zum fertigen produkt zu kommen ich
habe die arbeit wirklich komplett
unterschätzt ich war davon ausgegangen
dass ich so circa 30 tage brauche aber
wahrscheinlich habe ich insgesamt 30
tage alleine auf produkte gewartet die
von irgendwo zu mir gesendet werden
mussten im endeffekt habe ich jetzt
circa drei monate an dem projekt daily
gearbeitet sehr sehr viel arbeit
reingesteckt dementsprechend bin ich
mega happy wenn das ganze ding morgen
endlich online gehen kann und vielleicht
die ein oder andere person in die luft
mit meinen klamotten kosten okay was
habe ich jetzt eigentlich in dieses
gesamte projekt investiert neben drei
monaten wirklich aktiv arbeiten bin ich
so zirka viereinhalb tausend euro in
vorleistung getreten was meinen gewinnen
natürlich schneller sind samples die ich
an freunde und familie von früher
ausgegeben habe das denn ca
wenn ich es wirklich schaffen sollte
alle produkte zu verkaufen dann würde
das ein plus von 4000 euro brutto
bedeuten davon gehen natürlich noch
sachen die mehrwertsteuer und
einkommenssteuer ab im endeffekt steht
mit einem ziemlichen diese monatslohn da
bin aber trotz alledem mit unfassbar
happy mit dem projekt und solange ich
auf null damit rauskommen ist es auf
jeden fall die ganze arbeit wert gewesen
in dem prinzip ist dass die
entstehungsgeschichte von champion volt
gemerkt man wird damit nicht reich aber
es ist eben einfach eine
herzensangelegenheit das hat eine menge
spaß gemacht und es gibt jetzt endlich
genau die pieces die ich mir immer
gewünscht habe und die für mich immer
gefehlt haben das war es vielen dank für
eure aufmerksamkeit wir sehen uns morgen
um 18 uhr auf shaping the world.com
seit schnell
sofort aus